I checked the city I can't find her
maybe you checked the whole city yeah
look we have to find her before devourer
life's on the line she had another gig
this week I doubt you'd skip town
I would Dib neepy I suggest we find her
well since you asked has anyone checked
her web site I checked her web site dibs
of course we've checked your web site
no one has checked her web site iris
yeah I'm on it I'm looking now guys
she's still in town I just picked up the
first run of my next single love the
geniuses add some sounds how's blue
valley oh self-reflection and the battle
with a starfish from out of space huh
gives you perspective
hey everybody it's Charlie if he didn't
spot it during the episode they had
another callback to that Wally Teen
Titans vs star Oh
Easter Egg earlier this season with a
whole bunch of other stuff on this page
but there's also a bunch of Titans
related stuff so I figured this would be
a good opportunity to include that in
because we found out who the Doom Patrol
is going to be so I'll explain them
after I explain these Easter eggs here
but there is a new round of that flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and just leave
a comment on the video the text that she
reads it here just says how do you all
my blue valley show has been cancelled
due to some sort of starfish situation
but that adventure was part of this
story called Titans of tomorrow today
we're start a canola Teen Titans from
the future which is basically like a
Young Justice crossover so you have Teen
Titans vs. young justice people from the
future so like Connor can to become
Superman Tim Drake had become Batman
Cassie had become the full version of
Wonder Woman they come back in time they
wind up fighting their younger versions
of themselves the actual Teen Titans
rostered this was sort of post Jeff
John's era when they sort of rebooted
the Teen Titans and Young Justice comic
books by kind of combining both of them
they got rid of the Young Justice comic
book by killing off a character and then
a couple of those members joined the
Teen Titans but for the most part that
roster is not going to be the roster of
the live-action Titans TV show so I'll
explain the Titans stuff it's a little
bit separate from this
let it be known that all the DC TV shows
have done stuff like this where they
have like a really cool Easter egg early
in the season then they keep referencing
it later on this house
is pitching you know this house is
this house is but there's also a track
on her song list here that says ode to
Smashville
I almost thought it read ode to
Smallville but obviously Smallville
isn't anywhere on the tour dates here so
although there is a small bill on
supergirls earth earth 38 we don't know
about Smallville on earth 1 so I
wouldn't think too much about that until
you actually see Smallville pop up on
someone's screen somewhere like either
somebody says the name but the reality
is is that most things that exist on the
different earths exist on earth 1 so
like there is a version of Supergirl
there's a version of Superman Batman
like we've already gotten the Batman
reference on arrow this year so it's all
out there but just based on the
restrictions that the TV show brighter
z' have they'd to be really picky about
the way they reference stuff like that
so getting into Titans TV show territory
they finish casting the Doom Patrol and
it looks like they might be around for
most of the season like the episode the
Geoff Johns T's was episode 5 it's
called the Doom Patrol and arguably
that's gonna be the one that introduces
them like hey who are all these new
characters but on their IMDB page
they're listed for nine episodes there's
13 episodes total in this season so that
would mean that they have to show up
sometime at the end of episode four but
there's only four members of the team we
don't know what their storyline is going
to be but I'm assuming whatever they're
doing it throws them into the path of
the Titans because Ravens Ark is really
the story that drives the show forwards
like the terror of Trigon story where he
uses her as a conduit to come into our
plane of existence the thing is that's
gonna take a while so obviously there's
gonna be a couple of other mysteries
that'll intersect with that so while
they're worried about Trigon way off in
the distance you have all this other
stuff going on so we don't know if
they're gonna include any villains from
the Doom Patrol comics or if they're all
just gonna be Titans villains because
Doom Patrol has more of a James Bondish
feel about it with the way that it
writes its villains and it's stories
like general immortus Brotherhood of
evil which is obviously kind of like
Spectre the brain monster mala
so we'll see about that I wouldn't worry
too much about those other characters
because the show has already teased so
many big ones and that doesn't even
include Hawk and Dove which I think are
around earlier in the season but we have
Elastigirl robot man negative man in the
chief who's the leader so this clip
actually does a pretty good job of
explaining what their powers are so I'll
just play this really quick Chapter one
challenge of a timeless commander
general mortis mustn't get his evil
hands on an alien ship
execute plan 3 don't patrol we're way
ahead here chief
sorry no they ship never get him Nick
man you should have listened
negative mana separated for more than 60
seconds you die that only one hero
ascended my way elastic
[Music]
you okay robot man good as the day I was
assemble - now let's go stop old
sourpuss
sick sick 57 seconds
[Music]
whoo what a Doom Patrol find out so as
you can see elastic girl's powers work a
little bit like ant-man and the wasp she
can grow she can shrink robot man is
basically someone who's just had his
brain transplanted into a robot's body
it'll be really interesting to see how
the TV show deals with that I think
they're tending to opt for more
comic-book accuracy so I'm assuming
whatever he looks like it will be fairly
close to what he looks like in the
comics but negative Man is basically
somebody who got doused in radiation and
it created this negative self like a
negative astral projection of himself
they can do things he can control it but
it itself doesn't have a consciousness
it's just sort of like an avatar that he
wields like a finger puppet but like the
clip says he can only use the ability
for up to 60 seconds otherwise they'll
both die then the chief is the person
who put the team together he's this
genius that just sort of runs things
from behind the scenes
obviously wheelchair professor X but he
doesn't have any special abilities he
just super rich super smart with lots of
cool gadgets the 60s vibe of that
animated short was mostly just meant to
honor the original comics but the team
itself has changed a bit over the years
Grant Morrison did a really cool run but
obviously the bigger thing is that Beast
Boy used to be a member of the team when
he was changeling so that's sort of the
connection to them but don't patrol the
legends you gotta have some good stories
it was something I did once I'm a Titan
now you're moving too slow he's acting
strange even for Beast Boy I think he's
just worried the Doom Patrol raised him
they're like his family so I'm hoping
the way that they bring them on the show
is that they're looking for beast boys
help with a problem that they're trying
to solve then the Titans get involved
because he's already bumped into them
because they don't show up till the end
of episode 4 I'm assuming that most of
the Titans characters have already met
each other by the end of that first or
at least second episode there's only 13
episodes total so it's not like they're
gonna stretch this out the entire season
so whatever's going on with them
probably has some crossover with the
Church of Blood storyline because Church
of blood leads to Trigon they've already
cast the acolyte character he's part of
the Church of blood we know that brother
blood is gonna be a main character of
the series there's still a lot of
questions about cast members but they're
in the middle of shooting episode 6 or
episode 7
now the actor that plays Beast Boy was
posting these behind the scenes clip of
him doing voiceover for one of the
episodes I'm assuming probably episode
by over 6 is they're filming episode 7
by now but they're cooking along pretty
good they're not going to WonderCon I'm
assuming they're waiting until they
finish all their episodes and they'll go
to Comic Con this summer and that's when
we'll see footage for the first time but
we might get a teaser before then the
Titans writers room actually just
started a Twitter account and they're
posting pretty frequently so I think
they're just trying to get intercept
like hey we're getting ready to release
some information so there should be some
big Titans news in the next month or so
but obviously there's a bunch of Marvel
stuff that's dropping there's the
Deadpool TV series so I'll try to stay
on top of everything but just leave all
your video requests in the comments
below so no worries on in the giveaway
winner when I post my arrow episode
video that'll probably be up early
tomorrow morning I don't think I'll be
able to get it out by later tonight so
click here for that flash time trailer
and click here for that Avengers
infinity war Prelude story thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight